[Music]
[Music]
you're listening to a very special
quarantine edition of life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
with me as always did you like how i did
that why did you say your last name like
that well because i raised short i went
up on short then i thought it'd be fun
if i went down on long very clever and
fun right so fun oh we're having a blast
here in quarantine um
we're doing whatever we can to amuse
ourselves not whatever
easy settle down sorry um it's uh it's
day i don't know
um i hope you're all staying safe and uh
healthy and
christian how are you feeling america is
waiting with baited breath oh god they
haven't they've been losing sleep over
this question
you know this is when you know it's no
longer a problem when our own mother
stops worrying
she's chilling out that's true she was a
wreck because she didn't know until we
we had to tell her about we're talking
about christians covid and my
probable covid uh
experiences but diagnosis self-diagnosis
yeah
but so we had to tell our mother because
we knew we were going to talk about it
on the show and uh i'm glad we did
because then that article came out and
um she probably would have seen that on
the internet oh yeah she loves the daily
mail yeah okay well no she's but i do
know she likes
she likes gossip she sure does yeah but
then our older brother
damien got um
the other day he came down with a little
cold like a little head cold that was
pretty clearly not coated
but her concern has shifted from me
to him meanwhile which i'm happy about
meanwhile we have an 81 year old father
who um
you know can be a little stubborn
sorry bob if you're listening but he was
going out um
he's no longer going out now there's
they've been very strict about the
lockdown uh where we live but um he had
been just
taking
chances you know going out to the
grocery store instead of the dump going
to the dumps he loves going in the
dumpster yes he loves a routine and i i
know uh that's been interrupted so he's
been frustrated but he's also in a very
high risk group so we've been
worried about that and i've heard that
from other friends of mine that their
older parents are like stubbornly still
going out but to answer your question
about back to me oh sorry yeah um i
would say
yesterday was the first day that i would
consider myself
truly better oh yeah that's right
because you're the last symptom
that was lingering was your sense of
this [ __ ] it was this lingering chest
thing no no the taste has been back for
a couple days but
this chest thing i've had i had 22 days
of symptoms all told
and i didn't want to say this to you
even or to anybody but
for a while there i was my chest was
maintaining this
um
the same level of congestion for like
seven eight nine days straight oh my god
and i started reading all these articles
about people who have
coveted and they and they're have kind
of moderate symptoms for a while and
then after a couple weeks it turns into
pneumonia and i've heard that and i was
starting to get kind of worried about it
because i didn't feel myself improving
at all and i was doing trying all this
over-the-counter stuff like mucinex and
other cough stuff and um it wasn't doing
anything
and just a few like two or three days
ago i really felt it improving and now
i think i'm
maybe all the way better out of the
coveted woods such a relief i started to
get kind of scared yeah that's scary i'm
glad you didn't tell me that i would
have been worried i'd take after well
you know sometimes when you like say
something out loud it becomes yeah real
i know so as long as it's just a thought
in your head
yeah i thought you don't admit it out
loud there's something kind of hidden
about it yeah i know i've thought that
about you know sometimes i've i've felt
that way in the past about
relationships like oh i have a
i i had a certain feeling about somebody
i was with and like
this bothers me or this is the kind of
thing that i don't think we do
absolutely i'm the same way and it just
festers i don't say anything and you
kind of keep it to yourself and you
ignore it as best you can but once you
tell your friend about it or
then it's real and there's no turning
back because
you can force yourself to not
acknowledge a problem in your in your
own relationship especially us but once
you tell someone it's very hard for that
other person to forget what they've been
told about and then knowing that they
know it makes it materialize exactly it
makes it tangible almost
that's the wrong word but it makes it
real um speaking of wrong words yeah can
i quickly um clarify a couple things i
got some um a couple of the shorties
this past week i've noticed on facebook
for those of you just tuning in uh
that's what the fans of the show are
called
we've embraced it sure have i'm a shorty
yeah that's right on facebook my some of
my good friends are sure um and so a
couple of them have accurately called
me out us out more me i don't have
facebook no but it's it was directed
more towards me um but i think you're a
bit complicit too i don't want to
i want to throw you under the bus here
but two things that we talked about that
we were wrong about the shorty bus yeah
one
we were referring to um
uh
dorothy calling a a gay man oh dorothy i
had a feeling in a pejorative way but i
was partially right because i read it's
a reference from from clueless clueless
i was right about that but it wasn't
um they didn't refer to the character
christian in clueless as
a dorothy
they referred to him as a friend of
dorothy yes yes yes and i didn't know
what that meant but i did a little
research and i
discovered that it it references
um dorothy from
not golden girls but dorothy from wizard
of oz and it refers to the friends she
meets in the wizard of oz the tin man
scarecrow lion
are they're like um you know they're
queer they're they're um as as moe
pointed out the same zany exactly
exactly and then on top of that judy
garcia
they're exactly misfits from society and
the lgbtq community identified with that
oh that makes sense and now judy garland
obviously is a gay icon huge gay icon
so a friend of dorothy
is my guy his refers to
a gay man that's so interesting that
makes perfect sense so i'm happy i know
that so thank you shorty's and by the
way and do you remember didn't we have
this revelation recently we were
watching wizard of oz i hadn't seen it
in a while and it occurred to me how
for lack of a better word
stereotypically
gay some of those characters behaved i
guess zany now in in the parlance that
we're familiar with recently familiar
with but um watch it again with that
lens
oh
the line
yeah
yeah there's also a line everything was
like this that's a good line uh there's
a there's a ridge
there's a line that uh the
scarecrow says that's it's something
like we could i go both ways you go
either way either so a lot of people
think that was like a wink towards his
bisexuality and he was probably of the
three i would say the more the most rich
yeah yeah
yeah the scary girl is the most push
because the tin man is very small yes
and he's very oh well heart yes he needs
a heart and everything is dorothy
dorothy and and that didn't make sense
though now that i think about it what
the tin man needed a heart why was he so
heartfelt and emotional
i get why the um lion needed courage
he's yes he seemed desperate for courage
everything was he was a little bit i
also don't get why sorry i don't get why
this scarecrow needed a brain he seemed
smart enough
what was so dumb about the scarecrow
yeah he wasn't dumb he was just spazzy
he was klutzy yes exactly that doesn't
mean you're dumb yeah you don't have a
brain
a lot of holes in that whisper
and what's up with those flying monkeys
flying monkeys can't fly for that long
um yeah that was
that's an interesting movie to revisit
it's incredible it's still like for
storytelling-wise and the adventure and
the it's so fun and holds up have you
ever done the dark side of the synced up
dark side of the moon oh man how great
is that we should do that again that
that might be a fun question that would
be cool revisit
for those you have to do it perfectly
you have to time it perfectly otherwise
it's not that cool for those of you who
never had a freshman year in college um
in the late 90s early 20s i wonder if
that's still a collegiate thing
i just think it was yeah you can sync up
um dark side of the moon with wizard of
oz the pink floyd album yes yes sorry uh
and you do not like an astrophysics book
but like a neil degrasse tyson book um
but here's how you do it you think that
this on the third at the very end i
think of the third line second lines
right oh it is you might be right anyway
google this because we clearly well
shorties fact check us fact check us
yeah yeah uh on the mgm
uh intro logo with the lion roaring it's
either the second or the third roar i
think it's the last roar you might be
right uh at the as at the end of it or
the very beginning google this uh you
start playing dark side of the moon and
i feel like i'm 20 again it really is uh
it it works it's
[ __ ] crazy bro uh but it really is
cool and the best part is when uh
obviously you watch it with the sound of
the movie oh yes yeah the audio yeah
yeah good point um the best part there's
so many great parts during whatever just
watch just try it give it a shot give a
shot good quartering advice yeah um um
another one more correction that uh i
need to own up to
we
stupidly i stupidly i'm gonna own this
one
said um oh sorry can i make one more
point about the wizard of oz characters
please
it it makes sense that they should be
somewhere
in that neighborhood in that
zany whatever you want to call it
because they had to be just story-wise
it's a kids movie they had to be
non-threatening sexually with dorothy i
mean dorothy is a pretty
young woman and and alone i mean she's
with toto but you know how they get away
with that though
it's before they go to oz in the
beginning of the movie
you meet those characters they're in
their version that's right they're
versions of neighborhood and they're
older they're adults that's right who
are trusted that's right that she
already feels safe with you right so i
think that's how they get away with it
you're right you're right
and to maintain that innocence yeah yeah
yeah um so this other mistake i made we
said i said so without further ado and
we talked about how my french is bad and
how i don't speak french i always feel
silly saying without further ado yeah
total brain fart on my part i completely
messed up do you know why
think about it i do when you say without
further ado
it's not a deal it's a do i do you're
not saying
you say um
you say i bid you a jew i'm saying
goodbye to you
but without further ado is like much ado
about nothing it's english oh
duh yeah duh right yeah yeah
so uh shorty pointed that out good point
shorty i feel so dumb don't you feel
dumb yeah a little bit but
i i well i'm glad i know that now i'm
glad you shamed us for it shame me for
it
without further ado totally own this one
much ado about nothing i'm glad you did
and that's a great movie by the way to
watch it is a great playoff another
another quarantine advice yeah no more
quirk yeah there's a denzel washington
kenneth brianna
in much ado but nothing but i would say
very young kate beckinsale i think it
might have been one of the first movies
i would say in general uh
anytime we played hero make a mistake
like much adieu oh yeah without further
ado rather uh please oh yeah point it
out it's great we grow yeah grow grow
um
you don't have to like to grow
um
it's yes i had something i wanted to
talk about you know zoom obviously has
become a very you should point out not a
sponsor these episodes as you know are
ad-free um but if an ad happens to sneak
in there speaking of ads sneaking in i
got a great package
i made a comment on kristen bell's um
one of her i like making comments as you
are want to do i wanted to uh
and i got a a pickle it was about pickle
i made some offhand comment about
pickles uh
and this pickle company
sent me
a bunch of pickles um
in the mail so nice they were like that
i gave them my address and uh and they
were delicious shout out to grillo's
pickles they're delicious but the
rewards of your instagram comment yeah
what did you think of those because cl
i'm i'm a loyal i'm a claussen loyalist
if uh not an ad not an ad i just love
claws and pictures please yeah it would
be great um but grillo's was uh is now a
close second like clausten pickles to me
have a very unique taste yes it's a very
unique experience they've never had a
similar pickle to it right uh and
they're my still my favorite but these
gorillas they are
unique in their own right i would say
and very i would say the distinguishing
factor
is how garlicky and dilly they are and
very they have a great crunch on the
outside but the inside isn't quite as
crisp as a closing there's all this some
people like that there's all this like
fresh dill and other spices floating in
the we haven't tried the spicy one i'm
curious about that that's really good oh
you tried so garlicky yeah uh and they
sent me some
is it schwag or swag swag
swag is the way you move it was like
like bieber this is schwag i don't know
no no schwag is free stuff shorties uh
oh shorty's right now
oh boy i feel old and lame af yeah
yeah i feel old off yeah
hold up
uh anyway gorillas thank you um
what was i going to say before i
interrupted myself
oh i yeah zoom has become a
i think it was a thing zoom is a big
thing and we've been using it a lot uh
in fact tonight we have oh the other
night uh with my friend dan schechter
who directed uh made a movie called
after class not an ad but check it out
um
uh this he set up a trivia night and we
exactly we love going to bars and doing
trivia night and since you can't do that
now we did one on zoom
it was so fun uh
not to brag but
we won
did you know i was gonna say that i felt
it was coming i don't win many things no
i've never won trivia we won trivia
barely but we did so what we won uh 14
teams we were the top finishers you know
it was a tough one was how many m ms are
in a
the small m m bag on average on average
56. you were right yeah um but anyway i
was thinking we were talking about this
that it's hard to i've had a couple
social zoom calls and i know a lot of
people have been doing that it's i find
it difficult um
to know when to i mean it's always when
you're in a group setting
jumping in and knowing when to
when to say something you have to have a
lot of confidence on a zoom social chat
uh to know
what you're say you want to be really
confident about what you're saying i
find it a little intimidating
yeah because when you do have the floor
then
you're
like whoever is talking their their
picture pops up prominence is prominent
yeah so i feel like there's a little
extra pressure on the person so when you
do have something to say
you better be more sure of what you're
saying because it it's like that feeling
in a group where you're comfortable
yeah and everyone you know that that
feeling yes when you're talking in a
group and you haven't said anything in a
while or something and everyone turns to
look at you yeah you feel all the eyes
on you yes that's how it always is
that's how it always is or when you that
also that feeling when you are um saying
a story that maybe is going on a little
too long you feel it you feel it being
too long because you haven't tested it
in a social setting yet like this
podcast
yeah i mean this happens to me often i
can be pedantic or long-winded but um
you feel it much more clearly on zoom i
was on a
zoom call with like
funny people like people that i am
impressed by i don't want to like name
drop but there were some like heavy
hitters heavy hitters some former uh
guest of the show in fact
um and i felt that pressure to like no
but i think everyone felt that on that
call uh went to chime in yeah it was
it's difficult yeah that's especially
difficult that was like that was like it
was like being on a zoom call with a rat
pack or something
yeah
um
one of them was vince vaughn it's hard
to hold the floor of the fence but vince
was holding back i am name-dropping only
because
he was holding back a little bit and
like
vince for as funny and like
as as much as he can like take over uh
social setting a social environment uh
he's also very good at passing the ball
he kind of like
um you know it's a little bit like
michael jordan people forget that
michael jordan was a really great passer
too and larry bird
yeah another and a very demanding
teammate apparently yeah oh that's
another thing coming up um there's a
documentary coming out about michael
jordan i can't wait to see i'm excited
about that there's like
six or ten episodes it's multiple
episodes right well just about that 1998
team oh really i think it it uh profiles
that whole what a great team hey
speaking of final championship season i
can't wait speaking of that team um our
guest we just wanted to give a heads up
we usually don't do this uh we also
had a little face spasm we also usually
don't do these quarantine episodes uh
when we're not in quarantine but um
our guest this week is a man named rob
moore
um not
the wide receiver for the new york jets
and then i think current receiving coat
receivers coach of the i want to say the
cardinals but i might be wrong shorty's
fact check um but he is the uh man who
did the the original tiger king podcast
which is a one which is also a wondering
show uh it is now called
the tiger king uh you look it up i think
it's called the tigers it used to be
exotic over my dead body and now okay
yeah uh so rob is our guest and rob if
you so we just want to give a little
heads up and i say
it it ties into the chicago bulls only
because he happens you'll learn this on
the episode he happens to be a big
chicago bulls fan anyway um if you
haven't if you have one of you know a
handful of people who haven't seen the
tiger king and you want to
listen to the episode
in the venn diagram of people who listen
to the show
uh and and have netflix and and haven't
seen the tiger king i'm sure it's a very
small portion of you but i would say
before you listen to the next episode of
this show check out the tiger kids and
if you haven't seen
tiger king or have seen it or sick of it
or whatever
um
i would still recommend oh the podcast
this up not only the podcast but this
this coming episode on on tuesday yeah
with rob moore because he's a pretty
fascinating
guy in general and there is a lot of
tiger king chat but
um it's not all tiger king stuff and
he's just an interesting that's true
he's a very intelligent journalist and
writer and author so i think um it's
still very worthwhile to listen that's a
good point yeah he was fascinating he
was really interesting to talk to um so
that will be coming up on tuesday and uh
right now
oh i had a
i had a tweet that i wanted i often am
like i don't tweet very often because i
always second-guess myself if it's gonna
be funny or not um
and also i don't wanna get in trouble or
anything would this be a funny tweet i
think i ran this by you already
here's my prospective tweet i miss
baseball so much i'd even watch the
astros play
uh you did run that by me and i thought
you might get
too much anger from houston people yeah
and and people who accuse you of making
light of
the quarantine like this is your big
problem right what's happening now right
you think you are mr you know celebrity
you're right so i advised you again yeah
i'm glad you did okay
um okay uh you wanna do a check-in yeah
speaking of saying the right thing on
social media um let's check in with our
friend
justin is going to call
kevin
who kevin what yeah you know kevin bacon
a friend and a friend of the friend owe
the show
hello hey kevin
hey man hey man you are on don't say
anything weird
okay you're on
you are on the show
i'm panting
i was in the middle of a little bit of a
workout oh myself my son is recording
some heavy metal
and uh
in the other room so i'm walking past
the uh are you jumping rope or um are
those
those are
my slippers have gotten a bigger workout
i mean i've never worn slippers so much
in my life
first off first off i hate [ __ ]
slippers they're the ugliest things you
know i'm not even that much of a
i mean i'm not a flat fashion plate at
all but
i've nev i've never seen a slipper that
made anybody look cool do you have what
kind do you have out of curiosity now i
bet
if anyone's gonna make them look cool
kevin no they're really the definition
of grandpa slippers i mean they're a
they're just like a puke
brown
um
tweed kind of looking thing i don't know
why the [ __ ] i got these
well you probably didn't intend to wear
them so much when you got them
i really didn't and i've gotten to the
point now
where
it's so shameless that i just i just i
don't i don't i even wear them out like
like i said to kyra the other day uh uh
slippers or dog walking shoes you be the
judge
well this is the time where
people have so much more on their minds
that it's the last thing you're being
judged for i'm sure
if you're ever going to get away with
something like that um yeah yeah i hope
so how
how are you doing well how are you are
you so you're with kyrah and your son
yes i'm i'm doing i'm doing uh great and
um as i as i was um texting to you uh
yesterday
i'm i'm i'm practicing as much gratitude
as i possibly can
for um having a place to be being with
people that i love being healthy and
having food i mean you know reading
the statistics on the amount of people
who are hungry and in line for food
banks all across the country
um is you know
every every piece of news that i hear
i go
okay
uh do i slip into fear and despair yeah
sometimes yeah but can i also turn it
around and feel grateful for for
you know
for what what we have which you know
listen yeah um that's a hard thing to do
when you when you see
you know i watch the um
i watch cuomo uh you know pretty on on
pretty regular basis because i feel like
he's a great
uh great voice now he's a great voice
yeah and
but but the amount of people that died
in one day and uh in
in our city it's just it's just
heartbreaking it's really hard for him
yeah it's overwhelming but but thank you
for asking we're doing well how are you
doing well good uh good christian had a
minor
i think we both had mild versions of it
his girlfriend came back from a work
trip this is about a month ago now
and she had a pretty bad not bad enough
where she went to the hospital and we're
still not positive that we even had it
but
fairly sure that we did have it so um
but we're all healthy now and and
likewise kevin i just feel
when you texted me that i i i was i was
immediately ashamed for any
any
um
frustration that i had been like
wallowing in at all you know we feel
very lucky uh and and and and so much
gratitude toward uh we're gonna call our
friend in a second who's a doctor in new
york but
god the people who are
on the front lines of this and and
i i don't know i'm just sometimes i feel
overwhelmed
with gratitude and um
[Music]
and i not to embarrass you but you're
such a charitable person i know you
started something online that really
caught on that i think was so valuable
um
i i stay at home for you know people
tell you know just advertising who they
stay at home for how is that going and
is there another
charity that you like to support now
that you feel like should be highlighted
uh well i stay home for is going great
in fact it sort of had a different a
little um kind of uptick um yesterday
because the governor
you know the governor uh um
took took it took it up and talked about
it in his um in his press conference and
had that picture of a picture of him and
his mom and then
you know um so that's been that's been
great uh you know i
i
i'm i'm glad that it it went it went
well and i was really happy for all of
the you know kind of celebrity presence
but also the fact that it got picked up
by
but just you know regular people and
also
and and one of the first things and this
is probably a couple of weeks ago that
hit me was
um
when we first kind of put it out there
all of a sudden we heard from health
care workers going you know by the way i
can't stay home oh yeah and and uh that
was really powerful to me yeah that was
really like i mean i know it's a
at this point
uh things have moved so quickly that
it's something that everybody kind of
understands is that you know those
people are are
incredible heroes but but you know just
hearing it directly and yeah
relationship
was great i mean i think that um yeah
moving forward i don't know we have a
couple of ideas of some things now that
were are percolating but nothing that is
um
has firmed up yet but i feel like
hopefully something around um
um you know hunger because i really feel
like that's that's
um you know
such a basic need right now you know and
uh we'll see i'm gonna do a thing called
cameo that i had been resisting doing
but uh all of the proceeds from that can
go to uh any charity you want so i i
love this one called no kid hungry and
then there's one called feeding america
um both great both great charities yeah
i i completely agree so what are you
gonna do what do you do on cameo well
i'd see that i want to buy you on cameo
i don't know
well i'll do anything that's the thing i
was like what are the limitations like
can
i can you just have because i was
thinking about i have to record my video
my introduction and i was going to say
something like you know if somebody
likes me or it might be more lucrative
to
send it to the people who don't like me
and uh make me do like something
embarrassing you know like
humiliate myself for uh 100 no but is it
is it literally like anything that
anybody wants you to do you have to i
don't think you know obviously not right
you take this piece of celery
[Laughter]
uh yeah so i'll let you know how it goes
and oh yeah i just downloaded the app i
gotta do i i i i think you can obviously
like
oh there's a really funny one kevin you
should check out uh speaking of just uh
not saying yes to everyone every request
chris who is the guy uh sugar ray
christian's here
mark mcgrath
yeah the singer for sugar he did one and
he did it so well it was it was such a
tall order
somebody uh a
girl wanted him to basically break up
with her boyfriend for her
and he records this like breakup message
for
for this woman and um you gotta just
watch it i i i won't i won't shortchange
it by trying to describe it but it is
she's just gotta fly
she is breaking with you buddy she is
breaking up and buddy she's just gotta
fly see i you should have he should have
called me first you would have been so
much better
and i because i think the guy was a fan
of sugar ray so he would have
appreciated you know as painful as it
was to hear that he was being broken up
with he would have liked a little
some vocals from his hero um
speaking of uh vocals from your hero uh
i hate to i don't know how to else to
pivot to this but um
you posted
you're so great to follow on instagram
but uh you posted a couple days ago i
you and kira singing
one of my favorite john prine songs and
of course we just lost
john prine a couple days ago um
what what did he mean to you how
important was his music in your life
oh fantastic i mean i really um
i'm someone that uh kind of crosses um
genres a lot in the type of music that i
listen to and certainly and in the eras
of less music that i listen to we have
some friends that like never go past
1977 you know i i don't yeah i don't i
don't really you know
uh subscribe to that i i also well sugar
well sure yeah yeah i love sugar right
and people say you know well um you know
uh your rap is just talking and you know
i mean i i'm kind of like i i'm i kind
of feel like when people are making
music nobody's getting hurt yeah and so
i like all kinds i like all kinds of
genres but the thing that i always go
back to is the construction of a great
song and and that's the thing about
about john prine is that he he just was
just a fantastic
song writer you know and
you can
feel whatever
you know you feel about uh
voice or or you know guitar
you know
shredding skills or all the other kind
of stuff but but when you can sit down
or stand up in front of people
with just a guitar
and you know put uh of something across
that's really powerful like that it's
it's just amazing and you know it's like
like when you when you look at that
first record and you think about what a
young guy he was well this is why i was
surprised by how young he was when he
passed away i because
he to me he would he's been around
i i thought for decades and decades but
i i guess he's been making music since
he was in his early 20s which has been
50 years
yeah yeah i i read the um the oba today
in the new york times and you know heard
some stuff that i'd never known before
which was really cool like
that chris christopherson you know
was
somebody dragged into a show in chicago
and and he brought john to to uh to new
york to play at the bitter end and
and um brought him up on stage and uh
famous um
record you know executive and producer
jerry wexler was was there
and signed him to atlantic the next day
it's just one of those amazing kind of
you know kind of stories wow but yeah i
love i love this music and the and the
weird thing about that
kieran and i doing that song it's called
in spite of ourselves if anyone wants
yeah maybe a little bit
of this it's so good yeah yeah
yeah he's got that great duet with uh
irish yeah and and and it's it's a it's
a whole it's a hilarious song
um and kind of filthy too yeah uh but
but bigger balls than a big brass monkey
yeah yeah
yeah
um and but it's like uh you know convict
movies make her horny yeah yeah he was
sniffing me
he comes up with that like you know but
it's but but
there's this underlying kind of
sweetness and um kind of gentle spirit
to it yeah he had a sense of mirth like
there was a there's like real mirth in
speaking of that there's a there's great
video of bill murray talking about um
this i put it on my twitter um this
video has been circulating uh where he
credits john prine with
lifting him up from this very like dark
sounding like this deep depression that
he had been in
um bill murray not being able to laugh
and and wow and he credits john prine it
was it was some song of his i'm blanking
on which one now but uh
he's so cool um yeah you know he what
the weird thing about that song was that
karen and i were um we were just lying
in bed and it you know listening to some
music and it came across on spotify and
she was like oh [ __ ]
we gotta we we should work that up and
and we never it wasn't we weren't
working it up because we had heard that
he was not doing well or or because of
anything it was like it was definitely
during the the virus wow but um we just
so we just started you know playing
around with it and then
uh when we heard that um
his wife was sick and that and then
subsequently that he was sick uh you
know yeah
we just kind of went wow that's so weird
that we were just singing that song
weird it's so good i i yeah and i'm i'm
so it's so great to imagine you guys
well we don't imagine you can see it but
that you're you do things like that
you're you're home making music together
and it's really beautiful it's uh
i really appreciate it and uh thanks for
talking to us buddy we're we're gonna
we're gonna get going but um but i can't
thank you enough this is really fun
absolutely absolutely um and uh
christian hi hey sorry you might have
been so quiet yeah yeah it's all good
thanks for being on the show thanks
buddy
all right take care high and stay safe
and uh stay safe
yeah thanks pal all right take care talk
to you soon talk soon bye
the best he remains the coolest yeah
yeah
uh i didn't know how to get off the
phone like because we were gonna do
these quick check-ins and i felt
immediately like i don't wanna
but it was great he's so good it was a
good amount of time and he's so cool and
socially aware that yeah
right away you know we've talked about
this before on the show i think but you
know people who when they get a sense
that you want to wrap up the call they
pick up on it right away and they make
it very easy of all the things that make
him cool that to me is one of the most
impressive
it's and it's one of one of the things i
really admire about uh about people i
really value that people can the ability
to read
not not a room but in in this case a
social
yeah he is and he has such a way with
words he's a kind of poet oh i love i
wrote a great soul he does he has a
great soul i i wrote it down that's why
for him to recognize that
the beauty of john prime's music like it
anything he that guy not to mention him
laying in bed with his wife and they're
just listening to music together i mean
come on talk about goals
people use that term couple goals they
overuse it they overuse it and people
sometimes use it ironically but uh they
really are a couple goals yeah you know
i was thinking wait before i forget i
loved a lot when he said when people are
making music nobody's getting hurt yeah
what a great line um speaking of
overused words uh i just want to read
this really quickly i came across this i
started following
um
this site called history and pictures
and uh we're going to talk more about
this on the in this coming episode with
rob moore on this tuesday's episode but
we were talking about there have been so
much so many um
so much talk about so much chatter about
the tiger king and who should play those
parts in the movie
there was a photo of a woman um named
irina sendler
she lived from 1910 to 2008. listen to
this listen to what she did this polish
social worker and nurse who smuggled an
estimated
2500 jewish children out of
nazi-occupied warsaw she was eventually
caught by the nazis and despite being
tortured and having both her arms and
legs broken she did not reveal the names
nor whereabouts of the children i'm
getting chills that she had rescued she
was sentenced to death but managed to
escape
now
i
i imagine
imagine that how did she escape i don't
know but i want to know what's her name
irina sendler that'd be a good obituary
yes it would it'd be an incredible story
to tell and i just kept thinking and
again we're going to talk about this
with rob but like all the speculation
about the tiger king cast
this is this is what people should
should be casting you know
who should play this part who should
play this part
would you say i'm showing christian uh
julian bell oh yeah
that's a good call julian bell yeah
um okay
uh well thanks to kevin just
remaining the coolest um now we are
going to check it you know he also sent
me a very funny thing because i was
texting him to see if he would do this
and uh
he
he said uh
yeah
he said let me check my schedule and he
sent me a photo this photo of just like
a wide open that's really
by the way i bet he looks i'll put money
on it that he looks very cool in those
slippers of course whoa sorry
yeah he's like you know how like in the
way that the dude looks cool and
slippers yeah
she's like the dude but like really has
his life together yeah you know you're
being very un-dude dude okay um now we
are going to call our doctor friend and
do a quick in with him
uh dave kessler dr dave yeah dr dave i
know people don't call it i don't maybe
they do maybe you could ask yeah
uh he said if he doesn't pick up it
means he's doing something much more
important
hello
oh he's not i just said if you don't
pick up it means you're doing something
much more important so uh yeah i was
kind of like mid-sentence but i was
getting a little tired of that
you won't you don't know you won't note
the time that we're talking of course
because we i don't want anyone to be
offended yeah yeah exactly
you didn't deal with my emergency for
this but um obviously you are dealing
with a patient justin
um
thank you for checking in again uh
really quick dave um
what do you go by professionally do
people call you dr dave
um or dr kessler you know i just i just
roll with whatever people call me okay
that depends on the context it's fine
you know i'm a pediatrician by training
so i work with kids so you know right
so what are they lately when up lately
on telemedicine they just call me the
robot doctor or the tv doctor so oh
that's right you've been doing this you
mentioned that the other day and i was
unfamiliar with it that that people now
are doing televisions
medical visits how does that work oh
yeah i mean i mean in new york city i
feel like we've almost gone exclusively
to that you know
you know until it's a real emergency
um you know i i for our department sort
of have overseen our telehealth
initiative for the past couple years um
our hospital
has really heavily invested in it
they're one i think they're one of the
heaviest users of telemedicine and this
is columbia um yeah yeah before this
before this whole thing began so
fortunately we were in a good position
and then when when the crisis hit a big
part of our disaster planning was to
shift as much towards telehealth as
possible we grew exponentially had to
train countless people and really i
think that was a huge part of the
response in terms of keeping people from
going to the emergency room they had
this other outlet oh that's great
great timing yeah because you are the i
should have pointed out you're the
vp of innovation at columbia
i'm yeah i'm a vice chair of uh
innovation and strategic initiatives
yeah fight oh vice chair um
that's just so cool to say it must be
i know that you are in the midst of
the storm right now
what is it looking like uh dave can you
tell us anything about
the progress that it's making um
you know so you know i'm not i can't
keep as much up with the headlines so
i'm not sure where those are at but i'd
say the internal discussion and
analytics
is you know we're cautiously optimistic
there's like a uh maybe a plateau i'd
like to say um a little too early to
call it um the the they think that the
peak will be around the 11th
that's what you had mentioned the other
day on text
you said they're starting to see some
flattening of the curve and some is that
in certain outlying areas
yes i mean one way of saying one way of
looking at is like a few days ago we had
our first day where the discharges from
the hospital outnumbered the admissions
so that was a really that was a really
meaningful day for us
um obviously that you know
even though that particular number is
promising we're nowhere out of the woods
i mean uh this disease again is anywhere
from two to three weeks latency so um
even at its peak it's it's not a signal
to come outside and play you know people
have got to stay indoors right we'll
just we'll you know we'll never see a
flattening so this probably reflects
efforts from two weeks ago
in terms of people really moving inside
and so so um and then all the other
efforts you know going on with regards
to ppe so those numbers are prom they're
promising the sense that those
um
from its implementation
you've seen some
some improvement uh and hopefully
afterwards but in order to really
sustain that improvement and the
progress people have to stay inside
still
yeah and also make mo like when i say
improvement too we're talking about
flattening the curve in terms of not
overwhelming hospital resources right so
that so that we don't run out of
ventilators we have a daily dashboard
looking at the number of ventilators and
everyone a lot of planning is just a bit
about not running out of that that's
what we need to save your life when
you're critical but but make no mistake
i mean we're nowhere back to business as
usual all surgeries are still shut down
wow you know anything elective um you
know for primary care we have set up
telehealth but there's there's certain
things you're going to want to have to
come in person for them we're just not
we're just not um you know we're nowhere
in your business as usual yet but dave
city but dave you work in the emergency
room so what about emergency i mean what
about visits that aren't elective you
know that's a good question and um
you know to some degree and and you know
you got to understand er docs they have
a wry sense of humor but uh people look
around every once in a while and they
say wow we're finally just dealing with
emergencies
um because you know the reality is
especially in a
busy urban er yeah you know we're
dealing with all of society's problems
you know we're dealing with um someone
who maybe ha you know doesn't have a
good living situation and so we have to
sort of you know uh handle that in the
emergency room um and people are coming
for their primary care type complaints
because again the clinic system maybe is
not as as well funded or robust as it
should be
so i think you know we call the er you
know the great equalizer in that way we
are the safety net of society but we're
also that you know we'll see um the
issues that our health care policies and
our sus
our socioeconomic you know issues of
course we see that you know really
clearly in the er it's reflected so
right now emergency room is actually
dealing with emergencies yeah wow so it
makes me think now you mentioned people
who are in in
maybe hostile living situations
i think about them now too having to be
home so much more uh
is there a hotline or a number is there
any sort of
a resource that that people who are in
that position can call who yeah
well i will say that
um new york's doing this right and i
don't know the numbers off the top of my
head but but wherever whatever area of
the country you're in there are for
example domestic violence hotlines we're
seeing a big rise in that um you know
due to the situation yeah in new york
for the current crisis they're really
providing you know three meals a day for
for for children for example that
depended upon school lunch
programs and so so they've been really
well coordinated i don't know about
every state but i think um
you know it is important to think about
that some of the early numbers too just
on who this disease is affecting the
most is not surprising those at the
margins of society you know or you know
um or lower socioeconomic classes
they're obviously being adversely
affected by this as they are by many you
know yeah things and it's not a
political statement you know i i i i
look at it more than reality
you know like how we solve it
politically you know go at it but but
the truth is the truth and you know the
fact is that if the same people who
you know maybe do maybe can't um you
know go to a second home
are still in the in the workplace you
know from a coveted standpoint it
affects everyone so we truly if you know
this is a moment that hopefully people
take home we truly are one
we all um you know you might not feel it
every day but we all affect each other
in a crisis like this it's more
important than other than ever to figure
out how to really solve it all these
problems together that that are complex
and relate yeah and you're seeing it
firsthand and you have a vantage point
that few of us will have thankfully for
us but we're
also so thankful
to you uh for that and and for everyone
who's working with you and
uh we just remain so grateful dave and
um and also grateful for your guidance
personally christian wanted to let you
know that he uh just got his
taste back uh oh that's very good but um
maggie still can't taste and she's
starting to now
smell certain
smells she's describing
that's good yeah oh good
that's good because i mean i think mo
you know i'm saying you know i don't
know for sure yet what the what the
reasons are people tend to think it's
more related to the you know the nasal
passages and the cells there too and
that the loss of taste is maybe more
related to the loss of smell so the
smell is the primary problem so if she's
starting to get her smell back um that's
a really great sign that took a long
time though it did didn't it i know it's
been 20 something days
uh yeah so i'm sure it's the
it's on the on the very minor end of the
spectrum of what you've been dealing
with and
again thank you thanks for being on and
checking in and thanks for everything
you're doing
of course thanks thanks for checking in
again justin always here all right buddy
thanks dr david all right
okay okay bye dave bye
oh why am i taking my headphones off
uh
um
impressive yeah very impressive it's
equally impressive uh as as kevin bacon
is impressive i mean in a different way
yeah but so very uh god there's so many
people i admire i know this show uh you
know both have to admire a lot of people
this show really shines the light on
how impressive well i find certain
people well it's also we don't often
have unimpressive people on that's true
um we've been lucky yeah should we call
jerry that was no i'm kidding maybe next
week no i love jerry but um we don't
want this to be a four-hour check-in hey
let's read this letter great oh wow what
a great name roxanne roxanne i hate that
song you know i hate that song oh i kind
of like that song
no offense you know both have different
opinions of the police song roxanne and
i like sting a lot i really like sting
what's not to like i know and speaking
of cool yeah i mean give me a break
but that song annoys me a little bit uh
but i love the movie god damn is that it
you know i haven't seen that movie in
youtube
good quarantine i would like to see that
movie again steve martin is so good
who's telling us the story oh mo rock
was talking about steven martin
not having won an oscar for that movie
and he was
bitter yes which is not cool but uh
steve martin's obviously cool so that's
surprising okay roxanne
j this subject is what a great i can't
get over that name uh quarantine time
uh oh sca
this is i'm trying to read this uh g
e
uh with a
with a colon no exclamation point i'm
just reading what the word is
my guess would be
no
and oh oh she's testing that's not how
it's pronounced
she says
cayuga for hello justin and kristen
cayuga i think we'll learn what that is
absolutely love you guys and the podcast
thanks roxanne absolutely love your name
you know i don't know if we will learn
what it means i don't know if she
explains it but i read this letter
before i handle you and i
took the liberty of googling did you
know i did what kai yoga meant it it i
believe
it refers to um
a language of
an iroquois
tribe huh in that very few people speak
but you told me this that like there's
some people in canada and yeah a very
very small number of people in upstate
new york well i'm saying new york is
what i where i think of cayuga because
our mother used to always talk about how
much she loved she had great childhood
lake lake one of the finger lakes and
ironically is the
suburb that our parents grew up in in
rochester many native american names
indigenous people names we grew up in a
street called ankawa road piquant name
is a piquant uh the algonquin
so must i think refers the language that
you can't pronounce now
is referring to a very small group
you told me only 250 something people
yeah i think so that's what i uh googled
that's so but i might be wrong so
shorties correct me if i'm wrong that's
so cayuga
no
it's all right um
i finally caught up on all the episodes
now i'm just waiting for the next one
well here you go roxanne
so many socks stop
you don't have to put on the red light
so many celebrities that have grown to
love through your podcast that's cool i
was really inspired by your 102 now 103
year old grandmother you were so blessed
to have her around still and she's such
a sweetie by the way we got to check in
on her um well we have to do it off the
pod i guess but also we should do it on
the podcast uh we're going to do that
sadly i never got to really know my
grandparents on either side so i love
hearing about people that have close
relationships with theirs when this
virus first showed up on the scene i
didn't really think much of it as i'm
sure many people were the same can't
believe how this is all progressed and
who knew how much one actually touches
their face that is true uh i have my own
pet sitting business that i've been
doing for the last five years and now
that everyone has stopped traveling it's
a tad bit bad for business i bet
sorry i also work part-time for lions
foundation of canada dog guides where we
breed and train dogs mostly poodles and
labrador retrievers as service dogs huh
so how i'm getting by is
still working
that's cool much like a lot of people
yes of course we have animals to care
for but honestly it's okay because i
know we do great work and we help so
many incredible people with varying
disabilities and the dogs need us and
the puppy snuggles is an added bonus i
bet
we are working with limited and
restricted access to other people though
which is quite fine by me
don't get me wrong i love people but
sometimes it's nice to not have to
interact so much naturally i'm a quiet
and reserved person and my friends say
i'm a great listener little do they know
i'm just not actually listening lol jk
i try not to read or watch the news too
much in all of this it's very easy to
get wrapped up in all all of it and to
let the anxiety take over
i agree i try to stay positive and i
keep my distance from anyone and
everyone as much as possible to help
keep this nasty virus at bay and so that
i'm not possibly spreading it to anyone
else i haven't seen two of my sisters in
so long which is really the only thing
that's killing me i got i go to work
then home and have no interaction with
the outside world and i'm cool with that
there will be plenty of time for all the
social interactions and i'm sure in time
people will be getting back to grumbling
about having to go to a social event lol
that's true and i'd like to say that i'm
catching up on shows i haven't watched
yet or movies i've yet to see but i'm
the biggest office fan uh gotta talk
about that and watch it pretty
constantly
it's a show that puts me in the best
mood during the darkest times
so this time is no different love your
work and please if you read this on the
podcast don't read it out loud with your
canadian accent okay well
i didn't
even though it makes me laugh every time
ah
i have yet to meet anyone here that
speaks like that and i don't think i do
all the best
all the best and yeah away for the many
laughs again i guess that's like that's
for uh
canadian accent sucks
roxanne p.s uh should you leave her
number um i would totally [ __ ] myself if
you guys called me eh
well if she means that literally i think
we should call we should i mean put that
to the test uh we should we should rest
okay anyway thank you rosanne that that
was uh and it's really nice to hear
because our her view is very limited um
we've been staying home we've been
quarantined we've been lucky enough to
be able to do that as kevin pointed out
uh and so it's nice to hear from roxanne
from somebody who is
working continues to work i also like
that optimistic view of
of um kind of embracing and enjoying the
fact that
we i mean again not counting the people
who have to
go out and go to work and engage
but for all those who don't i think it's
nice to embrace the fact
that um
you don't have to socialize right now
and you can kind of get back in touch
with yourself and catch up on movies
like she said in tv shows that that's
crazy um because there will come a time
like she said she said where you at you
don't want to go to some social
engagement and um so kind of try to soak
it in as much as you can i think that's
really good advice it is it is um and
the office is good advice yes i was
going to say that's right you know you
just introduced me to the american
office i i was can you believe that
everybody america that someone had to
just recently introduced justin to the
well you know i've seen it i've seen and
every time i watch it i've always liked
it same with friends i don't know
friends that well but every time i've
watched it i'm like oh i really like it
i just uh i loved the british office so
much that whenever i don't know why i
just
well you know for a long time i resisted
the american office because i remember
when it first came out
okay the pilot episode
was line for line the same as the first
episode of the british office and i and
i loved the british office so much that
i was kind of offended
by the fact that they just did with
these different actors and i remember
thinking what a waste it was of steve
carell right it was great so i resisted
it for years and then a couple years ago
um at the behest of my friend liz and
and some other people who are who are
obsessed with the american office i
sat down and i binge watched the entire
series wow over the course of a few
weeks and i loved it it's amazing it is
so it's different than the british
office but it's so good yeah so
christian just started we just started
watching uh the first i started watching
the first season
god is it good um and uh you know i
think what we might do now is play play
out the show with uh kira and kevin
that's a good idea singing um
just a classic great mirthful
john prine song and if you're unfamiliar
with john prine i can't recommend his
music enough uh
just one of the best and and sadly we
lost him uh to this
[ __ ] shitty virus um a virus that i
hope you're all avoiding and steering
clear from and um and we'll see you all
on tuesday brian early yes with
tiger king
expert
good rob moore uh and again as christian
said do not feel the need to uh watch it
but if and if and if you're into the
netflix show check out rob's podcast uh
on wondering not an ad but kind of uh
called it was tiger king the tiger king
joe exotic here you go i think that's
what it's called now yeah it used to be
called over my dead body anyway uh thank
you guys for listening and he paved the
way for the netflix show i mean yeah
let's get that straight yeah the netflix
show followed
this his podcast so he paved
the way it was a really interesting
conversation yeah really interesting
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short oh that's right is hosted
by me
justin long yup yup and it's uh produced
and in quarantine episodes co-hosted by
me christian long and megan monaco
that's right senior producer is michelle
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marsha louie and
hernan lopez four and we thank them so
much for doing this ad-free wondering
foreign
[Music]
she don't like her rick's all running
she thinks crossing her legs is funny
she looks down her nose and money she
gets it on like
[Music]
[Music]
never gonna let him go
we'll end up sitting on the rainbow
against all outs
honey where the big dog cries
we gonna despite
our nose right
[Music]
she thinks all my jokes are corny
convict movies make her horny she likes
ketchup on the scrambled egg she swears
like a sailor when she shaves her legs
she takes me licking she keeps on
tickling i'm never
[Music]
is
[Music]
nothing but big old hearts dancing in
our eyes
there won't be nothing but big old
hearts dancing in our eyes
[Music]
be safe out there be good to each other
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
you